these are the seven greatest nen users
in all of Hunter Hunter if every
character in this world these are the
ones that Togashi himself has identified
as the ultimate nen users and this
information was unexpectedly showered
upon us through the recent yoshihiro
tagashi exhibition where some of his
memos were published revealing some
absolutely groundbreaking information
about nen which I've covered in another
video but also tagashi revealed a new
system of nen scaling essentially we can
now tell how good or how not good an end
user is judging by where they fall on
the scale or if it's a scale from up to
down should be more like that horizontal
it's kind of all the same but there are
four places that one can fall on the
scale the very lowest level of nenues is
known as great the word great I think
being very generous kind of like when
you come last in a race but you still
get a participation award the next level
of nen aptitude is known as excellent
which is greater than great but still
not as excellent as our penultimate tier
of Genius however even that highest day
may as well be a bucket because it pales
in comparison to what we're most
interested in here the ultimate tier
there are exactly seven characters that
Togashi has identified as being in the
ultimate tier some of whom you'll be
able to guess and some of whom you will
definitely not because there are a lot
of surprises here but something to note
is that this tier system is measured
based on the individual potential of
each nen user for example let's say that
you have twice as much potential as me
because you're very clever well that
would mean that my ultimate is probably
only the equivalent of your excellent
but for an example of this he is gone he
was identified as a great nen user
meaning that his nen progress throughout
the series mirrors hisoka's favorite
body part because they're both locked
quite firmly on the bottom a whole
entire shown in series later gone isn't
even past the first step but this also
makes a lot of sense because gone is a
child like a literal child and he never
even came close to achieving his full
potential well except for that one time
because gone also serves as the first
vow seven ultimate grade nen users it
was momentary but when he created an end
vow to use all of the Power he would
ever have gone by definition temporarily
reached the Apex of his potential so if
it helps we can also look at everyone on
a scale of gone to megagorn Meanwhile
some have gone's fellow enhancers fall
into some rather unexpected territory
with both uvigin and komogi being
assigned to the genius tier one step
away from Ultimate and that surprises me
especially with komuki because I
personally think she took her abilities
to the absolute extremes enhancing her
mind to the point where she was able to
constantly outplay Maryland and to think
that there was even more potential under
that is just wild on the exact other end
of the spectrum uvagin became a genius
by punching things punching things like
really hard however we do have one more
ultimate level nin user within the realm
of enhancement and that is Isaac netra
and I think that this starts to show us
the sheer Gulf between what it takes to
be a genius level and end user and an
ultimate nataro's dedication and
gratitude nen is unmatched even if most
people spent their entire lives focusing
on then the vast majority of them would
still never reach the ultimate level
because it requires pushing oneself
Beyond human boundaries which is a point
proven by our one and only ultimate
transmuter before that though we have
two identified genius transmuters being
hisoka and yupi hisoka being one of the
greatest thinkers and most efficient nen
users we've ever encountered and he
still isn't anywhere near his Zenith if
I had to guess I'd say it's because his
raging Schwing keeps distracting him
meanwhile up makes more sense because he
wasn't even alive for a hundred days and
most of his development came mere hours
before his death alright trivia time
apart from both of them being
transmuters what else does yupi have in
common with hisoka well the only other
thing they have in common is that they
have both orgasmed on screen hisoka
during battle and yupi when he gave his
body both literally and euphemistically
to marowen interestingly enough Togashi
doesn't make any note of kilow is great
although if I had to guess I would Place
him as great perhaps even bordering on
excellent because he shares gon's
infinite wealth potential and even
though yes he is stupidly powerful as he
is kilowa still has decades and Decades
of development ahead of him however as
for our one and only ultimate transmuter
that would be the ever astounding
biscuit Kruger Whiskey's path to
achieving the Pinnacle of her potential
is quite similar to that of netra except
instead of offering punches every day
biskey spent each and every day wishing
for a different different body just
casting that raw honest desire out there
into the void almost like a prayer and
over the course of many many years iski
was slowly able to manifest changes in
her appearance ultimately resulting in
her preferred form so I want to be
careful with the word prayer because it
brings up all sorts of connotations with
the religions and such with that said
there is a distinct connection between
nen and Faith because if you believe in
something that profoundly whether it's
true or not it's going to have a direct
effect on your aura output and we're
going to see this at Play Again with our
ultimate nen conjurer however for some
fun tagashi notes Here in terms of
conjuration apparently shizuku is a mere
great level nen user which is kind of
terrifying because she's already capable
of holding her own within the Phantom
troop meaning that her true potential is
far more powerful than I could have ever
imagined meanwhile only one step up from
her is knuckle identified as an
excellent grade which is probably due to
knuckle being a wavering young man very
much on a mission to discover himself
and so is unable to profoundly commit to
the one and only true God of compound
interest and a step further from there
identifies both genre and cortopia as
genius level conjurers gen through makes
sense he's one of the most underrated
hunt Hunter villains because well
because he's gone through but in his
defense he was extremely dedicated to
his life's passion of becoming King
explosion murder so that obsessive
quality took his abilities well into the
realm of Genius however can you guess
who our one and only ultimate conjurer
is the answer is probably not well
probably in fact likely because I did
mention it in the last video but our
ultimate level conjure is abengani which
was hugely mind-blowing for me at first
but I think up and Ghana stocks must be
doing pretty well right now because the
more I invest the more sense it seems to
make it's that connection between Nan
and Faith popping up again abengana is a
near-nexicist whose ability relies
strongly on an effigy ritual and
offering a prayer to the forest spirits
and despite exorcism being closely
associated with religion Faith isn't a
requirement for this sort of ability for
example the Chimera antenna also has an
exorcism ability but there's nothing
ritualistic about it so this whole
Effigy business is a product of
arbangana's pre-existing faith in the
forest spirits I should also say that
most net accesses should be at least
genius level if only because it is such
a specific niche of Nan with very
limited potential so provided you on to
complete more on with oral use you
should at least hit the genius level if
not ultimate ceiling pretty quickly in
this specific area or at least easier
than you would every other area notably
the most famous conjurer in all of
Hunter Hunter karapika is not listed
here however he was previously
designated as a dual Affinity user both
conjuration and specialization so maybe
just maybe we'll find him there moving
to manipulators now and this blew my
mind but in the like opposite direction
from abingana so what's the opposite of
blow suck it sucked my mind but it's
moral because despite being who I
personally think is one of the greatest
and most versatile auri uses in this
world he's still pretty much at step one
being identified as a great TNN user
however in this case I think moral's
versatility is exactly the problem much
like disappointing Vegemite on toast
moral has spread himself far too thin
yes Deep Purple can create essentially
anything for any situation but in
reality he's the Nan equivalent of a
dollar store yes he has everything you
need but it's also poor quality in
comparison to users who specialize in
just creating and perfecting one of
those things tagashi also said that it's
harder to level up if you're focusing on
multiple affinities and moral very
notably relies quite heavily on his
worst Affinity of transmutation but
that's why we can't use this system to
power scale nen users because Morrow May
officially be quite low level but he's
still a better Aura user than most
people who have reached the excellent or
even genius tears and speaking of our
two confirmed genius level manipulators
are illomizeldick and shirepoof no last
name let's call him shyapufant man but
illumi is definitely no surprise he
tunnels pretty hard into pure
manipulation and has taken his powers to
their utmost human limits the thing
about illumi is that he of all
characters is going to have quite a
rough time penetrating their ultimate
sphere because he's so well he's just so
devoid of Desire like there's nothing
pushing him that One Step Beyond like
biscuit there is some potential here
with the whole wanting to control Alka
thing but ilami's desire to control
kilowatt to then Control alakabai
Association would need to be something
that obsessively festives over years and
years and I just don't know if filami
quite has that in him with poof his
abilities break my brain quite literally
because that's very much what they're
designed to do I'm amazed that he has
even further potential but at the same
time after absorbing part of poof
marowam did demonstrate the next level
of his abilities by flat out reading
Minds whereas poof could only form
conjecture so I guess we know for a fact
that in this case full potential was not
reached but here is our ultimate level
manipulator and it's it's no one Togashi
did not designate a single character as
having reached the Zenith of
manipulation and honestly I can't think
of a single manipulator who would even
come close if not illumi or shayaproof
then it's no one it's getting to the
point where I think that manipulation is
the new sort of meme Affinity because
that used to be emitters but the emitter
class has not just one but two ultimate
level nen users and Razer is not one of
them not even close actually Razer is a
mere great tier user which is even more
shocking to me than moral I imagine it's
because he has a similar issue spreading
his abilities too thin across all of the
Greed Island mechanics but to think that
someone as disgustingly powerful as
Razer hasn't even left the starting line
is it's absurd overall Razer may even
have more potential than gone and fun
fact the very first time I was going
through Hunter Hunter I had already been
spoiled on adult gone because of all of
the memes however I didn't know that
this guy was gone so when I first saw
Razer I was like oh man this is it this
is the guy because Razer also wears a
white shirt and very shockingly tight
shorts so I was convinced that Razer was
going to be the guy who ended up being
gone and after seeing togashi's nen
levels look if Razer ever got off great
Island I now think that he could
absolutely read ShadowCon level for more
emitters nov is an excellent tear good
on him while Silva zaldick was granted
the rank of Genius even though all we've
seen from him are his two massive balls
and again I suppose emitting two giant
balls makes sense when your name is zul
dick but sadly for Silva he's only the
second best soul to commit as his father
Zeno is our first ultimate level emitter
and to dwell on this for a second Zeno
is more of a business and family man as
opposed to a faith man but he does still
have his core beliefs more so than any
other zoldick he believes in the art and
rules of assassination which is why the
thought of potentially having
accidentally killed komogi caused him in
a crisis that belief isn't shared by I
think any of his family who are much
more okay with collateral damage
especially illumi and meluki and kilua
and Silva and Kikyo and everyone
everyone's more or less okay with
killing people except for Zeno he needs
to be paid to do that it's immoral if
you're not getting paid meanwhile the
other ultimate tiramita is of course the
ant king meruim which I say
underwhelmingly because well because it
really just shouldn't come as a surprise
to any of us what will be a surprise
though is our specialist section
although this came with a bit of a
special note that Specialists are
inherently difficult to grade due to
well due to the specialness hakunoda is
our base level specialist and one up
from her is nail nostrad at the
excellent here and given that Neil's
motivation for using her ability was to
get all sorts of press cousins from her
father I'm surprised we even got that
far I mean even crawler used her ability
better than she did and speaking of
Rollo is only ranked as a genius level
specialist I say only because ultimate
definitely wouldn't have surprised me
but it's likely because crawler's
potential is nigh on infinite as a man
who can acquire any ability under the
right conditions pushing this power to
its ultimate form may require many many
more lifetimes than crolo has access to
a rather genius specialist is nefepito
inheriting the same rank as all of the
royal guard but our ultimate level
specialist is not karapika because he
isn't listed on the specialization
ranking either making me incredibly
curious about exactly where his aptitude
lands however our true ultimate
specialist is alaka and or Nani kazoldik
who possesses the single greatest
concentration of power in all of Hunter
Hunter because when you can grant
literally any wish and just Palm the
consequences off elsewhere the word
ultimate kind of becomes a bit of an
understatement but those are the seven
ultimate nen users in Hunter Hunter as
identified by Togashi